for a somewhat more obscure villain in
the marvel universe taskmaster sure
shows up a lot in my comments i get lots
of people asking for a taskmaster
training video and i think the reason
for this is that he has one of the
coolest and most interesting skill sets
in comics he has what is known in the
comics as photographic reflexes meaning
that he can see someone perform a
movement once and then perfectly
replicate that movement himself the
question of course that everyone wants
to know is is this possible
unfortunately as it happens i can't find
any examples any real-life correlates of
photographic reflexes that said there
are things we can do to become better at
picking up skills more quickly we can
learn to learn as it were especially
when it comes to our physicality we need
to prepare our bodies to be able to
perform as many skills as possible and
we need to prepare our minds our brains
so that we can more quickly learn the
precise movement patterns
yeah you always want to keep looking
ahead whenever you're doing any of these
spinning techniques because the main the
first thing people do when they go wrong
is they immediately look away okay and
as soon as you do something like that
you're going to lose completely where
you are always have something to sort of
spot that's in front of you so you can
you see i'm looking at that spot there
you want to look at the point until you
can't physically look at it anymore
often we hear the term general physical
preparedness we first do the kind of
base training that we might do to then
become better at performing any other
kind of movement that we might need so
general physical preparedness might be
used as the first miso cycle in a
periodized training program so it might
give you that cardio base some general
strength some work capacity that you can
then transfer to your training so you
become better at whatever else it is
that you want to do so yeah a lot of
this is to do with conditioning with
improving your cardio and work capacity
however what's also interesting is the
idea of building up your general
strength and a kind of basic performance
ross edgely talks about using more
compound movements in order to build a
greater overall strength base that you
can then translate different movements
you've built a greater mind muscle
connection greater control over your
body so you can recruit and draw upon
more strength whatever else it is that
you want to do so from here
i turn to here at the same time so i'm
still kind of looking over that shoulder
and pull that shoulder even back a
little bit more
and then i like initiate a sort of elbow
strike with this arm at the same time
the mini hook with this arm but again
it's not a huge swing
so from here as i do this
i'll sort of flatten that foot down
there
and turn around at the same time you do
that spotting then so this all kind of
happens at the same time obviously then
when we come round we're going to lift
this leg
but instead of
going upwards like you're doing a
jumping kick this is more a straight
travelling kind of attack kick we keep
the foot low down instead i personally
think that just using the traditional
compound lifts though might not be
enough for this if our goal is to become
like task master and able to pick up new
skills quickly then we need to practice
taking on new skills we need to learn as
many new things as possible because when
you learn a new skill a new movement
even just a new exercise this is an
education in itself this is obviously
true when it comes to more complex
movements like planche or like a muscle
up but it's also true for more simple
and straightforward things whether
that's a deadlift or a squat all of
these have minutiae learning new skills
helps keep you youthful for longer and
if you also want to look more youthful
for longer then check out today's
sponsor tiege hanley tiege hanley is a
men's skincare brand that's designed to
make taking care of your skin as easy as
possible this is a simple step that guys
can take to ensure they look and feel
their best which is all part of being
your most badass self with tees you not
only get all the products you need in a
single pack but also straightforward
instructions on how and when to use them
i've been using the level 1 system which
provides a daily face wash exfoliating
scrub am moisturizer with spf 20 and pm
moisturizer i really wish i'd started
taking skincare seriously sooner but i'm
relieved to see that it's not too late
to make some positive progress
teach hanley is one of the easiest and
most effective ways you can do the same
they have over five thousand five star
reviews and when you become a member
you'll get twenty percent off the retail
price access to exclusive deals the
ability to pause or cancel your
subscription at any time and free us
shipping and because tiege hanley is
sponsoring today's video they're
offering my viewers a great deal just
click the first link in the description
and you'll get 30 off your first box
plus a free gift don't miss out on this
amazing deal just click that link and
get started today it's almost like a
mini like reverse elbow strike
as well as kind of like a pork
which at the same time yeah that's right
so as you step to here
then you're gonna flatten that foot down
look around
and then you need to land out of this
spin with the foot turn fully around
that way
so it's even more than that so it's like
if you can the heel facing it and it's
much easier to speed as well okay so
hang on forward as well so we're here
yeah hang on so we're here and then it's
like
yeah
bang
bang yeah so for example with the
planche even a easier planche
progression you need to learn straight
arm strength you need to learn to lock
out the elbows and protract the scapula
to drive strength into the floor if
you've never done anything like this
before you might not even know what
these terms mean they're going to learn
a different movement that also requires
straight arm strength the same goes for
a kettlebell swing where you need to hip
hinge where you need to contract at the
right time and relax the body at the
right time you're learning more control
over your body
as soon as i straighten them before
it's because you haven't trained it this
is exactly what i'm talking about that's
it yeah that was really good
that's it man
what you'll find is there's a surprising
amount of carry-over between each of
these things so that you can apply your
skills learned in one movement to
another one you start to see the
connections and we can go a little bit
deeper with this by using my atnsp
hierarchy so underlying any activity
that you engage in are specific traits
that you need specific attributes as
well and even networks combinations of
muscle groups used together in order to
exert a particular effect so a lot of
things for example require a certain
amount of rotation whether it's throwing
a kick whether it's throwing a punch
whether it's throwing a ball or a med
ball all these things require you to
rotate the body and there's also a
certain amount of rotation in running so
by training the rotation of the body you
can actually become stronger in this
area gain greater control over this kind
of movement until then apply more to the
movements that you're trying to learn
plugging those gaps in your own training
and it's looking for patterns when it
comes to different types of movement and
the things you want to learn all of this
is going to increase your movement
intelligence and it's one reason that
liam who doesn't train martial arts was
relatively able to pick up the tornado
kick from grant because he's so used to
moving his body in different ways as
someone who does parkour and advanced
calisthenics skills he just has more
control and awareness of his body there
are certain activities and hobbies you
can engage in such as martial arts such
as parkour gymnastics that are going to
give you a very wide range of different
movement patterns automatically you can
then plug those gaps with different
things as you go
so if you just practice the step first
if you see where my foot lands i won't
do the kick if i just go like this
and then what happens is the kick is
pretty much
already done and it's basically just
using those steps if i don't go as far
you see it loses all of that yeah sure
and i'm like off balance whereas this
you should be able to spin
yeah
yeah and use those arms to spin but
don't worry too much about the yeah
there is also of course just a pure
strength element here and a mobility
element strength because if you want to
do something like a handstand push-up
then no matter how much control you have
over your shoulders and over your core
you're not going to be able to do it if
you don't have the strength you can
balance a handstand perhaps because this
is much more skill based but if you want
to perform a handstand push-up you're
going to need a certain amount of
pressing strength the same thing goes
for one-armed pull-up or all kinds of
other things even something like the
plant requires strength likewise we need
the mobility if you want to get into the
position for a lot of movements then you
need the mobility to be able to get
there again you can't copy something if
you can't get into that position no
matter how skilled you are at learning
it was like you went down and came this
way okay but it's more of a straight
axis okay so you're rotating around yeah
here okay so
yeah that's nice so you're doing way too
much with this leg you're lifting it
really high okay and you just need to
let it kind of follow so
think of the hips replacing so right hip
left hip
then here
that's the body side of things but
what's also massive when it comes to you
know potential photographic reflexes is
the brain because we're talking about
memorization we're talking about
identifying particular movement patterns
and to do this you need to listen to and
understand so many different things all
at once i've got my arms up yeah step
it's good
lift that's it nice yeah you don't
actually have to kick that high because
if you get that foot round your foot
will already be in position
yeah that's kind of what it is yeah i
think like just maybe drilling this a
couple of times yeah
it's
good yeah try not to drill it though try
to drill it with the momentum of the
steps so
at the moment as you're going one
two three that's right but i always tell
people to focus on this with the hops
because if you build that habit with the
steps some people can't do the hop so
particularly with more advanced and
complex skills and when you do that
you're using your working memory i made
a whole video on working memory recently
so check it out if you're interested but
essentially your working memory is your
ram it's where your brain stores
temporary information to then manipulate
and work with so if you're performing a
long multiplication in your head you
need to carry over the numbers you do
this by storing those numbers in your
working memory it doesn't just apply to
numbers and words it's also very
important when it comes to movement and
proprioception so for example if you're
trying to learn a punch you need to
remember to twist the hips and to push
from the foot you need to remember to
turn over the hand if you're performing
more of a boxing style punch or karate
style punch you need to go all the way
through you need to make sure you snap
it back quickly you need to make sure
that the other arm is back first i have
a bit of a tendency of punching before
the other arm has been fully retracted
you need to keep your guard up all these
different things you need to remember at
once and this is hard enough but then
when you go to perform the movement
that's much more information coming at
you and all falls out your head
according to a now old theory by paul
fitz and michael posner we go through
three phases of learning a new skill
that being the cognitive phase the
associative phase and the autonomous
phase during the cognitive phase this is
when we need to use our working memory
to juggle all that information and
studies do show that people who have a
larger working memory capacity even for
numbers find it easier to learn new
skills because they're able to integrate
that information together keep it in
mind as they're performing the movement
and thus they learn the skill more
quickly lately i've discovered i think i
have a slight deficit in this area and
it certainly held me back the good news
is i do believe it can be trained and
it's something i'm working on as you
guys know i built an app called biomind
which you can find in the link down
below it's free you can pay whatever you
want however if you would like to donate
something if you don't want to pay
anything then don't use paypal at
checkout because paypal won't let you
pay nothing while you can use apps and
things to train your working memory
what's also really good is to just once
again practice more complex moves not
only learning moves but also moves that
require more proprioceptive information
that require greater attention to your
senses juggling is a fantastic example
of something that we know can improve
working memory and focus and attention
and it's something you can do anywhere
and it's fun the same goes for balancing
on a balanced ball or performing crawls
or even climbing a tree and anything you
can do to increase brain plasticity
that's the ability of the brain to form
new neural connections even birth new
neurons is going to prove your ability
to learn that means learning regularly
which does boost brain plasticity also
can mean supplementing correctly i'm not
going to go into this in detail here but
things like magnesium 3 and 8 can be
really good for boosting brain
plasticity so can omega-3 fatty acid and
getting more sleep is really good of
course as well
so did i land a good tornado kick
unfortunately not really liam did a
better job than i did i found by the end
i was getting tripped over my own feet
kind of two in my own head and as i was
turning i was placing my foot down
before kicking which meant i was
essentially just turning around and then
kicking which isn't a tornado kick this
kind of clicked overnight and watching
some footage of the training back so
i've been practicing it over and over
the last two days my legs though were so
sore from drilling this over and over
again the previous day that could barely
lift my leg you know above waist height
i now need to go back and look at those
other things that he told me like what
to do with the back leg etc but i think
i now have enough pieces that i can
drill this and practice it i can't stop
doing it despite the pain so that's an
example of how good for you learning
skills like this is that is how we train
like taskmaster we keep learning new
physical skills keep learning new
exercises and in doing so we become
better at doing just that
if you want a training program that's
designed in this way that incorporates
lots of different movements from a ton
of different disciplines and at the same
time as building the kind of base
attributes and traits that you need then
be sure to check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 which also comes with over
two hours of instructional video i'll
put a link to that in the description
down below also like to say a massive
thank you to liam ellis and grant
stevens for working with me on this
video grant stevens of course teaching
us the amazing tornado kick you can see
how incredibly talented he is if you
want to learn that move he has a
tutorial over on his channel you can
check that out in detail i'll leave a
link to that in the description down
below also
liam ellis is a videographer and he's
working with youtubers so if you live in
uk and you're in a youtube channel and
you want to get some really high quality
footage he's extremely talented and i'll
put a link to his website in the
description as well and you can get in
touch with him there thanks also to paul
clutterbuck for letting us use his gym
at first for fitness in vista it's an
awesome coaching gym if you're in the
area and you want some coaching and a
great community vibe then check it out
thanks as well again to teach hanley for
sponsoring this video and thanks so much
to you guys for watching
bye for now
it's quite a good end shot